and now eight more urban dictionary
definitions you need to know lip banging
excessive making out in public everyone
at the party was grossed out by Jenny
and Michaels lip banging wash a perfect
140 character tweet on Twitter I'm never
more proud of myself than when I write
eight woosh dick butterflies a tingling
sensation in the groin caused by sexual
attraction Marissa is so thick
she gives me dick butterflies fleek on
point perfect we in this [ __ ] finna get
crunk eyebrows on fleek
dafuq banana polish hand lotion used for
masturbation Michael got a sandy handy
because jenny was out of banana polish
side text to privately text an
individual involved in a group text
Jenny and Kara side texted shade during
Carol's stupid group hang message senpai
someone who will never notice you today
my senpai said hi to me and my head
basically exploded I'm going to sleep I
don't want to text you anymore
Lisa wouldn't stop blowing up my phone
so I was all I'm going to sleep for more
definitions visit urbandictionary.com
while you're there be sure to look up
full donald it's pretty clever